those of you at home it's time to change
the channel turn down the volume or hide
the kids put them to bed now yield mr.
Schiff for storytime hour now when you
think back on your days in kindergarten
or first grade maybe you might remember
that time each week when your teacher or
maybe a special guest sat on a stool or
on the floor with children gathered
around and then fables poems fairy tales
or other stories were read aloud to us
wide-eyed children who took it all in
trolls wizards there were talking pigs
it was all magical the words and the
delivery made the fictional characters
come to life but then we grew up or at
least some of us did others are still
selling fiction and acting like it's
real life
I think today's testimony is among the
most significant evidence to date and
what we have just heard from ambassador
Sunland is that the knowledge of this
scheme this conditioning of the White
House was a basic quid pro quo it goes
right to the heart of the issue of
bribery as well as other potential high
crimes or misdemeanors well all day
shift tried play-acting the role of Sir
Lancelot who rushes in to slay the Trump
dragon of course the media playing the
part of objective journalists tried to
help him this is a bombshells but it is
explosive very explosive this is a
slow-motion explosion I can't emphasize
how explosive this is right now we have
witnessed today on live television
riveting ambassador soglin's testimony
has such gravity to it this was an AED
from mr. Soglin he exploded he actually
physically exploded that could have
gotten messy but when we leave their
world of make-believe we see that
there's no there there
President Trump never told me directly
that the aide was
conditioned on the meetings so it wasn't
really a presumption you heard from mr.
Giuliani well I didn't hear from mr.
Giuliani about the aid I heard about the
barista in 2016 and you understood at
that point as we discussed two plus two
equals four that the aid was there as
well that was the problem mr. Goldman no
one told me directly that the aid was
tied to anything
I was presuming it was presuming
thinking believing feeling we're going
to impeach a president on someone's
opinion in the absence of cold hard
facts there were a lot of opinions and
beliefs today but zero evidence my
belief was I believe I believe and
that's what I believe to be the case was
presuming that it was well I think I
think my personal presumption that was
my belief all my personal belief I'm
just telling you what I believe my
personal belief just based on as you put
it two plus two equals four oh he's good
at math too two plus two equals four
that's right
startling riveting explosive and how
persuasive well congressman bat Brad
Wenstrup although not a lawyer had fun
with that you see in mathematic fact two
plus two does equal four but in reality
two presumptions plus two presumptions
does not equal even one fact I've been
telling you for many weeks that this was
going to be an impeachment by opinion or
supposition or hearsay with no
underlying criminal activity nothing
even close to an impeachable offense
nothing that was said today change that
Congressman Mike Turner brought everyone
down to earth after you testified
Chairman's shift right now and gave a
press conference and said he gets to
impeach the president I states because
of your testimony and if you pull up CNN
today right now their banner says Soglin
ties Trump to withholding aid is that
your testimony today mr. mr. Messer
silent date I've said repeatedly
congressman I was presuming is it
correct no one on this planet
told you that Donald Trump was tying
this aid to the investigations because
if your answer is yes then the
Chairman's wrong and the headline on CNN
is wrong no one on this planet told you
that President Trump was tying aid to
investigations yes or no yes so you
really have no testimony today that ties
President Trump to a scheme to withhold
aid from Ukraine in exchange for these
investigations other than my own
presumption which is nothing he's
thinking how soon can I get on that
plane back to Brussels well speaking of
presumptions as Americans we presume
don't we that Congress will actually
work in the nation's interest then it
will pursue sound legislation and
oversight for sure with deep respect for
the Constitution yet in watching this
travesty play out we see just how naive
that presumption is and one final
thought recall how often Democrats have
trotted out this line you agree that the
president should not be allowed to ask
for the investigation of a political
rival and you said it's wrong to
investigate political opponents you do
think it's inappropriate and
objectionable to seek to get a foreign
government to investigate a political
rival am i right we call them
hypocritical is a gross understatement
tonight investigating their political
opponent it's precisely what the
Democrats have been doing to Trump since
2016 and to do so they abuse the FISA
Court
they used informants they trotted out
conspiracy theories they tried to take
down his family they deployed moles and
they used foreign intermediaries that's
all Ukraine aid was delayed for about a
few weeks Solinsky got his Trump meeting
without ever having to announce any
investigation and szalinski said his
conversation with Trump in July 25th was
normal no pressure
Americans are savvy and they're smart
and I bet most deep down sense that this
has been and continues to be a colossal
waste of time great economic news keeps
rolling in meanwhile folks are already
looking forward to the holidays I am
Trump's policies are meaning that more
people will get bonuses this Christmas
fewer are out of work that's all great
news even if in silence Democrats are
suffering from a wicked case of buyer's
remorse tonight a new poll in the
important battleground state of
Wisconsin shows Trump beating every top
Democrat candidate Gallup has his
approval numbers up two points even as
shifts grim fairy tale continues story
time is almost over but unlike when we
were four or five years old now we can't
wait for it to end and that's the angle